deal now this woman is being taken
seriously as an actual runway model how
insulting is it to the real models that
represent grace and beauty that we have
a tatted up porn star on runways this is
a disgrace if I was a woman that took
modeling seriously and broke my back to
become a model I would be absolutely
offended in protesting that a post-wall
porn star is now beating me for a gig
this is ridiculous we need to stop
catering to women and cater to men that
is not what men want or want to see a
tatted up porn star maybe for the night
but when I think of a model I think of
beauty and elegance and not this
nonsense that they're pushing today